whether I'm cancer they're off Morgan
people less time when I say ready it's
like I just opened the door on your
classroom there isn't a single entities
kid oh wow you don't feel that you would
be any safer if students were allowed to
carry asking about I'm Christoph thank
you oh yeah good all right so what do
you have here
so this was actually the first tattoo
that I got this spot right here is where
the second bullet went through where
else we shine so the first one live this
one instantly paralyzed the second
bullet went through here came out this
side broke two of my ribs collapsed my
lung Elektra you can't see where the
heart muscle stops and the bullet starts
really so I put both still there it
bullets are still in E so yeah these are
yeah Ronnie Achmed is the 23 year old
junior at Florida State University in
Tallahassee in 2014 he was shot on
campus by a former student he'd never
met today as an activist he's fighting
to keep guns off of college campuses how
many times that people showed you you're
lucky to be alive I mean I tell people
that every day yeah you know it's part
of this and I got the tattoo
there's been another mass shooting in
America it's I'm in a community college
in Oregon somehow this has become
routine
Florida State Columbine Virginia Tech
Sandy Hook shootings at schools and on
college campuses have become a uniquely
American phenom
in 2016 alone guns were fired in schools
47 times in response states are going
into very different directions some are
tightening firearms restrictions to keep
guns out of schools
others are pushing to allow guns on
campus for protection with Trump as
president the fight over carrying guns
on campus is reaching a climax I will
get rid of gun-free zones on school my
first day it gets signs okay
my first thing there's no more gun-free
zone last summer Texas became the eighth
state to legalize campus carry amid
protests Florida may be next Shana Lopez
Rivas is the face of the campus carry
movement here
she says she was anti-gun before she
says she was raped by a stranger on the
Florida State University campus just one
week before the shooting that injured
Ronnie then a friend brought her here
how did you go from coming here learning
how to shoot to now being this advocate
that's been embraced by the NRA and
other gun rights groups I was at the
range and I had that like kind of
epiphany him wow this could be used for
self-defense that I could use it defend
myself then she decided to share her
story with the Florida Legislature
November 13 2014 and November 20th 2014
remember those who see the first was
when I was attacked on campus the second
when FSU shooting occurred exactly one
week later
remember those dates when we vote for
campus carry and that was it for a vibe
from that point forward it was just okay
I guess I'm going to advocate for this
Shana has since been featured numerous
pro-gun publications including the NRA s
online channel representative for
Florida students for concealed carry
Shana Lopez Rivas is with a Shana thank
you so much for your time today
thank you for having me on the show I've
had people call me a paid member of the
gun lobby of which if the gun lobby
decides to watch this I would love to
get paid I mean that'd be great I could
do this for a job is there anywhere that
you think people shouldn't be allowed to
Carrie I don't believe in gun-free zone
working and so I don't believe that
there should be country though it isn't
just students like Shana we're weighing
the prospect of carrying guns on campus
I will tell you if you had a couple of
the teachers or somebody with guns in
that room you would have been a hell of
a lot better on citing an uptick in
school shootings more than a third of
states now allow elementary and high
school teachers to bring guns on the
school ground okay so when I say ready
it's like I just opened the door in your
classroom teachers and school employees
here in South Jordan Utah are taking a
concealed carry course specifically
marketed to educators and learning what
to do if they encounter an active
shooter how do you go about approaching
the idea that if you concealed carry in
a classroom one day you might be forced
to make the decision on whether or not
you're going to shoot a child I of
course want to protect majority and if
that means taking out that one
particular threat if it means saving the
rest of my classroom and yeah it was it
was hot my child was in your class I
could Thank You tiller as my life kami
Botello is a sixth grade teacher and
former Marine has this been something
you've been wanting to do get a
concealed carry permit hear it go to bed
in my head but it's been a long time
since I've carried a weapon that I feel
I have to be especially with the
situation I'm in I have to feel very
confident very well trained under state
law Tammy isn't required to do any
further training beyond the concealed
carry permit course before she brings a
gun into her classroom
nor is she required to tell the
administration or parents that she's
doing so but with the potential of
active shooters in mind she opted for
additional training and a virtual
reality simulator with software
specifically designed to mimic a school
shooting hey you feeling nervous yeah
this is going to this yeah okay yes
[Music]
Wow yeah yeah card contrabass yeah
so what did it feel like actually be in
that scenario
oh very possible very realistic was
there any part of you during that
adrenaline as you recognize that you
were in school that was hard about
shooting excuse that first one I just
felt even if I were to make such a
horrible mistake I need to move on to
find the real threat
critics of arming teachers point to
accidents that have already happened in
2014 a professor in Idaho accidentally
shot himself in the foot and last summer
an elementary school teacher in
Pennsylvania left a loaded gun in a
school bathroom or was later found by
students do you think this when you are
ready you'll be bringing it in
oh yeah unfortunately we live in that
world now we're back in the day when
someone wanted to commit suicide they
just committed suicide now they're
taking people out in the process what
you say to a parent who might not
understand why you want to carry a gun
to school and might not approve of I
would try to explain to them that I
would give up my life to protect their
child and whatever you meant there isn't
a thing I want is for these kids in the
classroom life right now we're at the
Strozier library at the FSU campus we're
just less than two years ago the gunman
came right here and shot three students
has since become a galvanizing spot for
a lot of students who want the right to
carry guns on campus but for Ronnie who
was shot here he sees it another way
technically you know right here's with
started I heard the pop I was standing
not the first table the second table
right over there
the gunman seen here in this video was a
lawyer and former FSU student who had
told friends he was hearing voices see I
am a victim of covert harassment and
electronic harassment and gang stalking
I'm what's called a targeted individual
and I saw this guy walking around the
bush right there what's that in his hand
as he was turning saw the silver of the
top of the gun started to make the turn
to try to you know run away of what that
shot and I had one normalcy address to
the emergency
what a scary day
okay so this is one after she campus
yeah no animal actually left a shoe
Police Department on this wagon again
there's brick over there so you know as
the puddle just kept getting larger and
larger it wasn't a puddle it was just
line after line of blood just seeping
out further and further away from me
I picked up my arm that was completely
shattered and I all I could see was the
bone I didn't want it to be then even
immediately after an incident I made it
very very clear that even if I was
carrying that day it wouldn't have made
a difference because by the time I
recognized what his intent was
I was already paralyzed do you can't get
it Jeff's false sense of security
absolutely this idea that the you know
often young men who have never been to
war zone or dealt with conflict real
conflict or you know anything of that
nature think that just because they're
holding a gun that they they have the
training and the know about to take down
an armed assailant it's unreal the
situation Ronnie is fighting against is
spreading across the country seventeen
states have banned carrying a concealed
weapon on a college campus but 24 states
grant individual colleges and
universities the authority to decide
whether to ban or allow guns on campus
eight states allow the carrying of
concealed guns on public college
campuses and Tennessee allows only
faculty members to carry
Shana doesn't like to share just how
many guns she currently owns but did say
she is always looking to buy more hi I
think that I'm going to go with the 43
like I had planned before huh which do
you end up gay in the boxes and why is
it that that's what you wanted I wanted
a smaller carry on the one that I
currently have now and why is it
important to you that people not know
that you're carrying you know I want
that element of surprise I don't want
people to know that I'm carrying if I
need to use it I want them to be caught
off guard would you feel safer knowing
that there are more students on campus
carrying guns I would feel safer knowing
that I am carrying yes right I guess
yeah what about having all of the other
students the college campus you know
people are younger there's often alcohol
and people make all kinds of decisions
when they're in college they might not
make when they're adults with the other
colleges in the United States that have
had campus carry there's never been an
incident in which somebody with a
concealed carry license used a gun in a
way that like they violently tried to
attack somebody you believe that more
guns on campus would in general make
people safer I think that any general
whether on campus are off more guns
equals less crime
Shana
invited John Locke the author of the
best-selling book more guns less crime
and a vocal proponent of gun rights to
FSU to build more support for the campus
carry movement
I know make constitute arguments to me
it's simply a matter of what saves lives
in 2003 lot adopted a fake persona
online pretending to be a former student
who praised him for his work in an
attempt to promote his research he later
publicly apologized for it these killers
it's amazing how warped their minds are
and what they view as their goals they
want to get media attention and they
know they can get more media attention
to more people they can kill a lot
argues that mass shootings happen in
schools because shooters seek out
gun-free zones the only type of law that
we found that made any impact on these
mats public shootings was the presence
of concealed carry laws when concealed
carry laws were passed there is about a
60% drop in the rate of mass public
shooting Ronnie and other members of the
campaign to keep guns off campus walked
out at last lecture they'd been told it
would be a forum for a debate about guns
on campus but it wasn't they were going
to write all the rules they were going
to write all the questions it was
essentially a a one-sided kind of debate
what's the hardest part for you
listening to somebody like that come to
campus people he conspires for sure
because you know one person saying
incorrect and ignorant things isn't
exactly the deal what other people start
continuing false information on that's
where the issue comes and people start
believing that those you know statements
the next day Ronnie invited me to watch
his morning routine pain is a constant
but he pushes through these exercises
and the hopes that he'll one day walk
again you never push yourself I'm
reducing I was one of the healthiest
people that I knew of the last five
years yeah especially involve tenting
school what do you want people to know
about what it's like like it is every
day you can't understand what it's like
to have to change your entire life in a
moment's notice to do everything
differently it's have to struggle
significantly more than you've ever had
to the severe was obtained every morning
Ronnie goes through these routines
motivated by his resolve to keep guns
off campus there's so much that we can
do to help make people feel safe you
know the fact that we haven't even let
non-lethal weapons on a lot of campuses
before allowing the most lethal question
that we have available is you know
absurd
to check out our entire documentary
series where we explore issues like
smart gun technology the influence of
the NRA and gun violence in Chicago make
sure to subscribe to aj+
and watch more docs